[Music]
[Music]
yeah hello there's a giant hand on the
screen oh hey mom can you can you make
yourself landscape there we go
you're on you're on camera now okay yes
yes you look very beautiful
I really never face time you know we
talked on the phone a bunch but we never
I never think to FaceTime you it's nice
to like to see you so we're all skyping
with our mothers to talk about
motherhood we've been shooting this big
series of videos exploring Parenthood I
learned a lot about what you had to go
through three times like I knew that
being a parent was really hard but it's
soaking hard some of the things that
we've done we started with wearing fake
pregnancy bellies there's something
called labor pain simulation and then we
got to play with a baby which was like
the cutest baby in the world
so we also you know remember when we had
those robot babies in school yeah we had
to have those robot babies again so I
was wondering what you know what your
pregnancy was like what having what
having me was like try Lucy with eula
stuff you know you you didn't to me used
to run in place
oh okay I gave birth to this summer and
I was
you get very hot at the end and they
also got very fat so you so I made you
fat and sweaty for me your heart it is
faster so everybody in pretty bad I saw
it for you of her oh you thought I was a
very silent girl yes yes that one
thought I had to I had to have their
breasts though you and I watched a lot
of those I Love Lucy
oh you likes like feeling when I kicked
totally it wasn't like what is this
monster inside of real right yeah we
didn't have a real thing we just have
like a little pouch with baby goo what
was it like when you delivered me I mean
was that the most painful thing you've
ever experienced awful I was screaming I
think the whole hospital must have heard
me it's something but you know you know
I love takes it and at one point your
heart chakra
[Music]
in your case I has you in 15 minutes
videos hospital you know I never held a
baby before
oh no have my first experience changing
a diaper oh yeah I was Tara didn't tell
them about it yeah I made like paper
towel mittens so I wouldn't get poop on
my hands cuz I was like 12
did I poop a lot everything how was I
like when I was a little baby was I
crying a lot didn't cry music good I
always say to everybody smiling laugh
just like now sounds like me well I'm
not it's Mother's Day oh yes so I wanted
to call you and say that I love you you
know I I tell you I love you a lot I
hope I do I hope you know it I think you
know it all of these things that we've
done have been like simulations right
they haven't been the real thing is
there anything else that you experienced
during motherhood that was significant I
[Music]
don't know we did this whole thing to
just try and like see if we could
understand what it's like to be a parent
what is what it's like to be a mother
and what I realize is I mean I'll never
know through this process I've been able
to imagine the bigger picture a little
bit
don't let the try guys Mother's Day
videos scare you
whatever you bow through it's well worth
it it's awesome to be a mutter and look
at these kids look what I raised um so
lucky
raising kids a severe joy again it's
going through and it's weirder present
and I behave okay parenting is full time
24 hours all the time and I always have
to think about it thank you
[Music]
I love you so much you're like the best
person in the entire world you're so
important to me thanks for giving birth
to me
happy Mother's Day on Sunday I'll call
you though thank you so much for talking
to me I love you oh well happy Mother's
Day mom a really amazing thing and I
feel like I have a deeper understanding
of it and that greater perspective I
love you very much and thanks for being
my mom as classic